Welcome back everyone
This is the way. Ahsoka has started
and Luke Skywalker is nowhere to be seen.
He's not helping a soldier deal
with Thrawn or this threat
from the Remnant Empire.
The shadow councils are being called
in this part of the timeline,
even though what they're doing right now
is heavily,
heavily
based on the original Thrawn trilogy.
Heir to the Empire from the nineties.
that storyline
completely revolved around Luke Skywalker.
So it is a bit strange that they're trying
to step around the character
so much right now,
All explained what's going on with him
and how they're going to use the character
going forward.
he will be
part of the upcoming Thrawn storyline
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing weekly videos
for all of the Ahsoka episodes
and for The Mandalorian Season
four after this,
the next big series after Ahsoka
Cronologia likely will be Loki Season two.
We'll talk about that
during my Marvel videos.
The larger Thrawn storyline
will continue in Mando Season
four before the Thrawn movie happens.
That's why they had all the Shadow Council
Thrawn stuff
at the end of the Mandalorian Season three
because the Ahsoka storyline,
like everything in
this part of the timeline,
is meant to cross over.
they're using all the series right now to
tell their heir to the Empire storyline.
the last we saw of Luke Skywalker.
He was training Grogu in the force
like a traditional Jedi.
That was the whole thing with his Jedi
Academy is he was pursuing
or trying to rebuild a Jedi academy
and rebuild the traditional Jedi order.
they didn't get into this during his
episode, but he's on the planet office.
That was another deep cut from the legends
candidate, Dave Filoni.
Jon Favreau brought back.
it used to be the home of the Jedi Order
for many thousands of years.
After their initial schism
with the order that pre-dated the Jedi.
If James Mangold gets to make that Jedi
origin story movie set
25,000 years ago, some of this stuff
will become Canon again.
but before the Jedi Order, light side
dark side Force users were all part
of the same order called the Jedi
on the planet Titan, which they also use
during the Mandalorian Season
two re canonizing that That order
was something more akin to the die
bend do The bendy was a concept.
Dave Filoni also re canonized in Star Wars
rebels.
It was in the original treatment
for Star Wars,
a new hope when George Lucas was creating
the idea of force users in the Jedi.
they had a schism in the light side
force users left to start
what you now know is the regular Jedi
order on the planet office
the dark side force users left
eventually be killed by the New Jedi Order
like they had some subsequent wars
then a group of survivors
from those dark side forces eventually
found the Sith race and the Sith
Empire was born and the rest was history.
this is all Knights of the Old Republic
era stuff.
They might get into this
in future movies and series
if they start doing more after this
Origin of the Jedi movie.
It just depends on what happens
the next several years.
Needless to say, Luke Skywalker
making his Jedi Academy on off us
is like then bring things full circle
with the legends Canon Origin of the Jedi.
he intended for Grogu to be
his first real student at this academy.
Technically, Leia was a student briefly
around the events of Mandalorian season
one, like about five years
after Return of the Jedi.
But she was only with him
for a little while
before she left to give birth to Ben Solo.
then, when given the choice, Grogu
chose to leave.
His academy, returned to Mando
after only two years of Jedi training.
He was with Luke Skywalker for two years,
according to Jon Favreau,
even though the way they cut the episodes
together
between all the shows, it seemed like
he was barely there,
that was how they explained Grogu
getting way more powerful so quickly.
Luke Skywalker
also on top of having two years with him,
did you do basic Jedi training?
help him unlock his Jedi training
he'd done back at the Jedi Academy
before Order 66.
And you have to remember that
Grogu was over 50 years old,
closer to his mid-fifties now,
because so much time has gone
by since Mando season one.
So he had been at the Jedi Academy
for years, since
well before the events of Phantom Menace.
Grogu, who then leaves to continue
his own exploration of the force
that's separate from Luke Skywalker,
more traditional Jedi teachings.
He'll pursue his own path,
just like Ahsoka.
That's meant to be their connection
they share.
They don't consider themselves
traditional Jedi,
even though there's a lot of Jedi training
left in them.
In Jedi beliefs.
that was why people got so confused
when they were dropping Ahsoka trailers
and they kept calling her a Jedi because
during rebels, she very clearly told in a
can Skywalker
Darth Vader that she was no Jedi.
But while Luke was training Grogu, Ahsoka
visited them.
Dave Filoni
Jon Favreau haven't said exactly
how long she was with the two of them.
It was only supposed to be a little while.
She was there for the entire two years
that Grogu was there.
The whole idea is that her visiting Luke
was meant to pay off
all those fan questions.
Everybody had about her relationship
with Annick and Skywalker's
children after the Clone Wars
episodes, the Rebels episodes.
So much of Star Wars
revolved around Luke Skywalker and Leia
just in that part of the timeline
that everyone kept asking
if Ahsoka ever learned about them
and if she ever met them,
because at least up to that point,
we never actually seen
that happen on screen.
So I don't think any of the books
covered their meeting
either, or them referencing each other.
So it was like a really big deal.
And Star Wars to have them actually
meet each other on screen.
the way that Jon Favreau talked about it
after the fact.
Her visit was more about her
just checking in with Luke
to see how his Jedi Academy was doing
and how Grogu was doing,
because now
they also share this connection
to the force,
like she and Grogu, who have a connection.
while she was there, even though
she only briefly alluded to it,
she basically is meant
to have talked to Luke about his father.
And again, Skywalker and Luke is
meant to have told her what happened
on the Death Star during his final days
in Return of the Jedi
the whole idea
that he ultimately redeemed himself
and turned back to the light side,
trying to kill the emperor
before he died, there was a ton of law
that they had to pay off.
Like, did Ahsoka feel kids
death in the force when he passed?
Did she have a force vision or feel
what was happening
during their battle in the Death Star?
What was the soldier doing
when that happened?
she was meant to be a very active
part of the rebellion.
So like she was around
during the events of Return of the Jedi,
the original trilogy is that most of
it was spent in the outer rim serving
as the Fulcrum character,
like the point of communications
between all these rebel cells
part of the issue with the IS.
So the character is
that she wasn't created till like after
Revenge of the Sith came out in theaters.
So they had to find a way
to explain what she was doing
during the original trilogy.
Well, they couldn't
just go back to those original movies
and just edit her into them.
Then there's the idea.
They had to address
what's going to be a so close relationship
with manikins, children going forward
in the timeline, because, for instance,
her species lived much longer than humans
for sensitive members of her race,
lived to about 200 years old.
so we've been when
Luke and Leia die in the distant future,
she'd still be around middle age
during that time period.
She look about the same that she does now.
the idea right now
is that even though most of Star Wars
storytelling is following grogu
mando Ahsoka the Mandalorians perspective,
Luke Skywalker is still meant to be
a big part of what's going on right now
in the timeline with the Thrawn character.
most of the big changes
they made to the original heir
to the Empire
storyline are in service of them avoiding
having to do too much CGI, deep fake
Luke Skywalker.
so they find a lot of ways for him
to not be around all the time.
the in canon universe reason
why Ahsoka didn't tell Luke
about all the Thrawn stuff that's going on
in the space whales, the Pergolas.
Ezra Bridger,
whether you agree with it or not,
is that he's continuing
to build the Jedi Academy.
Busy with that,
searching for more for sensitive students,
which he has not found yet.
they're still in that in-between
time period after Grogu who has left
and before a bunch of other students
begin.
It is academy like a young Ben Solo
that's meant to still be a few years off
of all the Thrawn heir to the Empire
storyline that they're doing right now.
I think the idea is that if Dave Filoni,
his first Thrawn movie goes well,
they do a full trilogy for that,
then there might be some overlap
with the ending of that last movie
and Luke Skywalker
getting a bunch more Jedi Padawan students
they do plan to involve him
in the Thrawn movie.
There might be another small cameo scene
right before that
just to address his involvement
during the actual movie.
But they're not going to do
a giant Star Wars movie
in this part of the timeline after doing
so much Luke Skywalker the last few years
and then not let him come back
and be part of that most of you
noticed this during the Mandalorian season
two and the Book of Boba Fett.
But by the time they got to the Boba
Fett episodes, their technology
for doing Deepfake
Luke Skywalker had gotten way, way better
and they fit well,
more confident in giving him a bunch more
speaking lines, generally
doing way more a much bigger scene.
that's because they were using
all of his cameos to test their technology
and figure out
how to do characters like that
so they could pull off cameos like this
without it
ruining the memory of the characters
Generally, though, they try to stay away
from way too much deepfake cameos
from any of the characters.
But there's like a bare minimum
that you need
so that the storyline makes sense.
But it would be weirder
if they never did Luke Skywalker at all
during this part of the timeline.
The other major reason why
so good didn't have a long conversation
with Luke about Thrawn.
It's because they were just
leaving that for later in the timeline
during a later episode.
At some point,
right before they want to bring
the Luke character back into the story
that way it's much easier for them
to change Luke's story in the future
if they think of a better story for him
or a better way to use the character.
The other major reason
why you haven't seen Luke Skywalker
in the first couple of episodes of Ahsoka
is because they're waiting
till like the last possible moment
to bring him back before the Thrawn movie
in Moseley the Skywalker,
who's relevant to Ahsoka in her
storyline, is and again, Skywalker
that's why you've seen so many Anakin
Skywalker scenes in all of the
Ahsoka trailers, the new voiceover dialog
that Hayden Christensen recorded.
That dialog is a flashback to him
training Ahsoka during the Clone Wars.
We might get to see
that is an actual flashback.
So it could just be a voiceover,
a cameo scene in her remembering,
but fingers crossed that
they actually shot new footage for it.
the major stuff that they've changed
from the original Thrawn trilogy so far.
Is the original Luke Skywalker
cloning plot became the Grogu cloning,
but they've largely wrapped that that was
meant to be just moff Gideon as planned.
The other members of the Shadow Council
didn't really know or care about
what was going on with that.
They have not done.
Mara Jade,
a lot of people asking about that,
that could wind up changing,
but I'm not going to hold my breath
because she became Luke Skywalker's wife,
the mother of his child who was named Ben
Solo after Obi-Wan Kenobi.
And they just used the Ben
solo name for Kylo Ren.
Luke and Leia had twins
instead of just the one child in Dave
Filoni already used the Jason name
from Legends for Hera in Kanan.
Son Jason's in Dula and he's going to
show up in the Ahsoka episode soon.
This is the back of his head
in the trailers.
I don't know who's playing the character,
though,
during that original Thrawn storyline,
the Jedi master that Thrawn was working
with was named Dangerous in Rey.
Stephenson's
character is called Balan Skull.
His backstory is completely different
in what Thrawn had that Jedi Master doing
originally was totally different.
there was a whole Mount Tantas plot.
Palpatine was a much bigger
part of the story, even though he was
dead at the time, which Dave Filoni kind
of repurposed in the bad batch episodes.
He turned that mountainous plot
into the Grogu's cloning stuff and Emperor
Palpatine cloning And we just found out
about the latest change
to instead of being lost in another galaxy
like they are in Ahsoka.
Thrawn had been searching
the unknown regions,
which is just another part of the main
galaxy, They'll probably be a bunch
more changes to the original Thrawn
storyline throughout the Ahsoka episodes.
I'll point them out when we see them.
Like they're kind of taking things
in a new direction and it's loosely based
now on the original Thrawn trilogy.
So you'll see a lot of familiar things,
especially if you're a child
of the nineties in the eighties.
Let me know in the comments.
When do you want them
to bring Luke Skywalker back
into the Thrawn storyline In present day?
If you have any other requests for bonus
videos, write them in the comments below.
My full Ahsoka Episode 3 video
will post after they release it.
Click here for that all.
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!